Well, first thing's first, I wanted the answer to this question to be in minutes,
but the time we have up here is 8 hours
so let's convert that to minutes to start off.
So 8 hours times 60 minutes in one hour gives us 480 minutes.
Great, so this is the exposure time for an 85 decibel sound.
We want to know what this is for a 100 decibel sound,
so let's look at this last piece of information.
If the exposure time before damage is cut in half every time the power doubles,
we need to think about how many times the power doubles from 85 decibels to 100 decibels.
We knew before that it was 5 times.
So if the power doubles 5 times, that means that our exposure time is halved 5 times.
So we need to take 480 minutes and multiply it by one half five times.
That doesn't seem too bad.
However, we know that if we want to multiply by one half five times,
that's the same as multiplying by one half to the fifth power.
One half to the fifth is one over 32, so we're actually dividing 480 by 32.
And that gives us a final answer of 15 minutes.
Now remember that every time the power doubles, we have a decibel increase of 3.
Some sources state that instead of the exposure time being cut in half for every three decibels, this happens every five decibels,
but I think it's better that we stay on the safe side.
I bet you never thought we would end up talking about ear health
by the end of this course.
But that just goes to show you how incredibly applicable algebra is,
in all spheres of life. In just this lesson
we've talked about everything from sound
to carbon dating, the Dead Sea Scrolls, and the population of the world,
and this happened in just a few questions.